[Música]
ah
cuando estaba en el colegio tenía un
profesor que nos decía con frecuencia
niñas la cabeza no es solo para ponerse
demonios porque nos decía esto solo a
las niñas no recuerdo cómo se llamaba
aquel profesor ni qué asignatura nos
enseñaba pero sí aquella frase que
seguramente al igual que en mi caso
debió quedar grabada en la mente de
muchos
que nos quería decir el profesor que por
ser niñas solo usamos la cabeza para
ponernos adornos para vernos bonitas no
para pensar que por ser niñas somos
menos capaces de razonar entre mis
compañeros de colegio era común que se
dijeran pareces una nena
una frase usada para reprochar algún
comportamiento relacionado con falta de
fuerza o falta de valentía o un
comportamiento sentimental en casa de
mis abuelos paternos se solía decir las
mujeres son de la casa y los hombres de
la calle en ese entonces no era
consciente de las implicaciones
negativas que frases como estas pueden
tener en el desempeño de las niñas en
matemáticas
seguramente has escuchado frases
sexistas como estas no llores pareces
una niña
calladita te ves más bonita las niñas
visten de rosado y los hombres de azul
debes aprender a cocinar para conseguir
un buen marido esa profesión es poco
femenina
estas expresiones son un reflejo de las
creencias de una sociedad que se van
transmitiendo de generación en
generación y se van normalizando con el
paso del tiempo perpetuando estos
estereotipos de género los estereotipos
de género no solamente se hacen
evidentes a través del lenguaje sino en
el comportamiento de las personas por
ejemplo en ambientes laborales es más
común que las ideas expresadas por
hombres sean escuchadas y llevadas a
cabo que aquellas expuestas por mujeres
es más frecuente que se usa en adjetivos
para calificar el trabajo de una mujer
haciendo alusión a adjetivos de como
ella se ve físicamente mientras que en
el caso de los hombres se usan adjetivos
relacionados con el rol que ellos
desempeñan profesionalmente y no como
ellos se ven porque restar cuando puedes
sumar
la manera en la que hablamos es un
reflejo de lo que pensamos y es de
acuerdo con nuestras creencias que
actuamos en nuestra cotidianidad si a
una niña se le dice con frecuencia que
la cabeza solo les sirve para ponerse
moños el día que se enfrente a un examen
de matemáticas de plano va a dudar de su
capacidad como si ser mujer la hiciera
inherentemente menos capaz de pensar y
de resolver problemas con efectividad y
confianza
el uso del lenguaje comportamientos
sexistas afecta la vida y el bienestar
de niñas y mujeres pues las minimiza
reduce su confianza y condicionan su
comportamiento y sus aspiraciones no
sólo pierden niñas y mujeres perdemos
todos pues sociedades más desiguales
tienen menos posibilidad de progresar
las matemáticas son una ciencia dura una
ciencia asociada a la razón lo contrario
a los sentimientos es por ello que se
cree erróneamente que no son para las
mujeres son una disciplina competitiva
pues la respuesta a problemas
matemáticos es generalmente una sola o
aciertas o no evidencia de ello es que
las mujeres obtienen en promedio menores
puntajes que los hombres en matemáticas
en pruebas estandarizadas
es decir en exámenes cuando se debe
escoger una sola opción entre varias
posibilidades
los resultados de las pruebas pisa
muestran las diferencias que obtienen
hombres y mujeres en matemáticas en
diferentes países del mundo pizza es un
examen liderado por la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
un organismo internacional que evalúa
las habilidades y competencias básicas
en áreas como matemáticas ciencias y
lectura en jóvenes de 15 años en el año
2018 participaron 75 países en la
mayoría de ellos las mujeres obtienen en
promedio menores puntajes en matemática
que los hombres sin embargo hay países
donde no hay diferencias en el puntaje y
otros donde incluso las mujeres les va
mejor que los hombres ellos eligieron
sumar en lugar de restar
en un estudio que realizamos en el
laboratorio de economía de la educación
de la universidad javeriana para el caso
colombiano usando pruebas nacionales
encontramos que a temprana edad es decir
en 3º de primaria no hay diferencias en
el puntaje que niñas y niños obtienen en
matemáticas sin embargo en quinto de
primaria estas diferencias se empiezan a
ampliar en contra de las niñas en noveno
grado de secundaria las diferencias son
cinco veces más grandes en el último año
de bachillerato
estas diferencias o brechas son siete
veces más grandes que las encontradas en
primaria e incluso la desventaja para
las mujeres en el desempeño de
matemáticas permanece entre aquellos que
están en el último año de universidad
hay estudios que muestran que los padres
de familia tienen mayores expectativas
por sus hijos varones que por sus hijas
y por tanto los apoyan y los impulsan a
que realicen carreras stem
es decir carreras relacionadas con las
áreas de ciencias ingeniería matemática
y tecnología
en la mayoría de los países sólo el 30
por ciento de aquellos que eligen
carreras stem son mujeres
en otro estudio que realizó una
investigadora italiana publicado en el
año 2019 se encuentra que las ni a las
niñas les va peor en matemáticas en
aquellos colegios donde han estado
expuestos a un profesor o profesora con
fuertes estereotipos de género
si desde pequeños niños y niñas son
tratados de manera diferente se les
enseña que deben comportarse de manera
diferente tener gustos diferentes elegir
oficios diferentes y jugar con juegos
diferentes hombres y mujeres terminan
interiorizándola y terminan haciendo lo
que la sociedad espera de ellos este es
estos estereotipos son reforzados además
por la publicidad y por la falta de
modelos de roles a seguir es decir la
falta de más mujeres siendo
visibilizadas en roles que suelen ser
tradicionalmente masculinos
por fortuna algunas mujeres logran las
habilidades que se requieren en
matemáticas y eligen carreras intensivas
en esta área yo por ejemplo elegí
estudiar economía una disciplina que usa
como herramienta de análisis los métodos
cuantitativos pues a pesar de estar
expuesta a un ambiente poco propicio
para esta elección tuve la fortuna de
contar con unos padres que me inculcaron
la importancia de ser competitivas
matemáticas y de su utilidad para
resolver problemas cotidianos
sin embargo me pregunto qué pasa con
aquellas mujeres que no tienen la
motivación y el apoyo para no dejarse
influenciar por estos estereotipos de
género de no estar enfrentadas a estas
barreras cuantas más mujeres tendríamos
en su máximo potencial eligiendo
libremente lo que ellas quieran ser y no
lo que la sociedad erróneamente espera
de ellas
lograr la equidad de género en el
desempeño académico es un imperativo que
no debe dejarse al azar cada uno de
nosotros puede contribuir al cierre de
estas brechas empieza aplicando una de
estas tres acciones primero identifica
qué frases sexistas acostumbras a decir
y elimina las de tu lenguaje
segundo
si escuchas de un familiar colega y
amigo alguna frase sexista o un
comportamiento que refuerza los
estereotipos de género cuéntale como
estos afectan la vida y el bienestar de
niñas y mujeres
tercero papás profesores y todos
aquellos que son constantes en la vida
de niños y niñas promuevan un trato
igualitario entre ellos ayuden a las
niñas a fortalecer la confianza en sí
mismas impulsen las a participar en
actividades de ciencias y matemáticas y
hacer competitivas en estas áreas
por ejemplo si vas a regalar un juguete
a una niña regalarle a aquellos que
despierten su curiosidad y su gusto por
las ciencias o aquellos que le ayuden a
reforzar su capacidad de análisis
matemático contar medir reforzar su
capacidad de ubicación espacial o
regalarle libros libros que cuenten
historias de mujeres inventoras mujeres
matemáticas mujeres científicas y en
general mujeres realizando roles no
tradicionales de manera que las inspiren
y les muestren que sí es posible suma no
resta
[Música]